et le pendant les pendants les nos
arénas aussi scénario dit ce qui est des
pommiers hin1 de folie quoi amener cette
fois le score à l'inversé non cette fois
jusqu'au rien versé mais en fait ils
jouent tous les jours illustre y voit la
white stream les deux est ce que ce
match est comme ils n'ont pas indiqué
non sûr que non sûr que non c'est à dire
qu'ils jouent le jeu
sûr que non parce que si savard deal
avec chaises comme miss stream ray sur
les chaînes chasse kop ciel et la barre
sauter stream perso donc mais c'est bon
bah russe le super g c'est du très haut
niveau le jour les partis c'est être au
niveau de faire nul non b4 répandre un
message juste en même temps c'est un
petit strip épouse est ce que les gens
sont arrivés
tu penses tu as fait quoi ça nul on se
fait nulle ménard au il est quand même
assez impressionnant je trouve à après
une longue france qu'il n'a aucune
chance
on est tout à fait d'accord mais tenir
en blitz déjà contre nepos est quand
même là il veut jouer à 3,2 en août au
prix d'1 million us restent eux le plus
orageux passé peut-être fausse et kat
d'abord mais tu manques de coûts ce que
dès que tu bouges le fou je te fâche 4
hawass et de peut-être moins ses deux
dauphins de la c3 c3 et va te faire roi
des huns
non il faut qu'ils voient la varroase
deux frégates il va te faire quand les
varois s'est trahi la 3d un auquel tu
vas faire fou j'ai deux projets deux
ça doit être un rené de l'icann a ok il
doit considérer qui peut pas la tenir
avec le temps et qui doit changer
quelque chose
ah non ils veulent arnaquer au contraire
aïda peuvent le faire ne veulent
arnaquer mais il prend des gros hits
quoi faut g45 ff7 prend b3 foucher bref
s'il va la gagner la roue ont faut six
recettes trois mois j'ai deux bleus 3
ça donne une petite annonce il ya fou
j'ai vite à il est d'un anneau mais du
coup ça fait dam dom dame prend m6 échec
mais ça ça a également très bien joué ah
non mais c'est nul alors est enrobé de
roide moisséens aller ils gagnent
maintenant
bref non la world team forteress ne le
furent mes jolies parties à lévis ils
seront co pourquoi un nom mais c'est
comme je disais en début de stream c'est
beau quand même marot il est bon quoi
parce que là n'est pas je pense pas que
fin même si je vous parle 100% quoi je
pense que dans des films comme ça il est
chaud quoi ils ont même lots d'ailleurs
tout simplement son le site
ils sont pas problème niveau et ça te
met quand même le niveau 10 cas où si
mathieu qui montrent assez souvent à
3003 hélas 3003 j'allais te poser la
question comme l'un des trois mille 3000
points juste effet rhodia il a comme nom
ou un peu plus même si route je crois
que les 3780 3002 s'est beaucoup fait 2
cf 3100 j'avais pas c'était un bon
guillaume un fait le siège est vraiment
bon il va bien il a trois minutes avec
quelques aussi met en scène trois mille
ça me surprend parce que je ne trouvais
pas très bon allez en scène il remonté à
3000 as un truc de ouf mais chope ntic
je devrais parler j'ai déjà battu
c'est qui le français igor nataf
les tonnelles si le voir à 2009 tu as
des gens c'est un mais joue vraiment
bien j'avais déjà regardé ces partis et
je sais prof ouais ouais je très très
bien il joue très très bien mais la
cadence à doit pas être trop pour lui
gagnent 3 + 0
ouais non mais je joue vraiment trahi de
juin 3 plus de ouattara non non non et
je rejoins 3 0 il est vraiment très très
fort 2009 vrai nom c'est gros niveau
quoi je le voyais pas si folle 2007
moi je t'ai 2007 soit je me relance ou
moins j'essaye on a tellement rien à
faire faudrait qu'un jour je me passe
aux objectifs de type 2007 et 2008
annoncé je suis très bon site internet
3009 2009 ouais c'est même mieux gozzo
quoi c'est vraiment fort good old boys
28,5 ans quand i try hard il doit
arriver à 29 aussi je ne mettais pas si
fort il gore en blitz mais bon on n'a
pas dit c'est que c'est un très bon
joueur par correspondance mais justement
mais justement je serai plus fort en
partie longue maintenant et je voudrais
les taureaux grdf trois nains dans la
foire 3 c'est pas mal
trois noms a pour moi c'est ma tonne ou
alors fou hezekiah l'ancienne ceylan
domaines web et d'élus amiral font pas
reculer
bien que non quand elle a fait ce nom de
grand maître
moi je les jouais quand on était assez
jeune j'avais gagné j'avais fini par
dire oui c'est un bon joueur mais il
passe souvent des tours et je les jouais
dans le championnat d'europe de random
là j'ai pas gagné un truc je fais
souvent un hacker en fait un des canons
sera tout le monde sait pas trop pour
moi oula c'est comme ça c'est toujours
un nom
l'ouverture a tant que je remette bien
pour les gens oui les tournants commencé
à quelle heure quelqu'un a demandé dans
leur foi il faut que je vais être le
lien à wisques à la même minute by
minute est vrai qu'il ya personne qui
s'inscrit là parce que j'ai pas me le
dire
du coup ouais en fait c'était
passionnant quand même le truc de naro
dit ce qui est un plus comme n'y a pas
de kitsch et ils vont pas du courreau
créer un pitch exprès non ils vont
relancer des tournois pour les pour les
gens là les arénas ça va reprendre une
par semaine
il va bientôt y avoir une annonce
officielle moi j'aimais reina faut juste
se font n'importe qui peut jouer rennes
et ce qu'il faut commencer rhénan pas
cette année normalement tout le monde
pourra participer y aura des prix tu
pourra tenter ta chance
c'est vrai que je m'en servais très très
fort par contre je préviens oui d'autres
non mais là en fait pour gagner ce truc
là facturation avoir de nouveaux firoud
china canard dit ce qui n'est pas feinte
c'est même pas sûr que tous avoir un
prix non non en fait je dire que je
pense c'était pas 27 27 56 e en blitz
t'es pas favoris tu vois c'est chaud
c'est très très chaud mais blanc
commence à être mieux là c'est bizarre
je faisais extrêmement triste pour
l'union il peut jouer des tours ces
quatre noms par regarde le cheap au 1
quai des trains c'est encore décalé
l'échiquier a oui ça c'est bizarre que
salar décalé marrant ça fait un double
décalage ça devrait pas être le cas ça
devrait pas être le cas mais ret merci
d'avoir fait du sahara décalé ce qui est
rare qu'est né peuvent pas faire nul ce
qu'il a plus de temps
am il est pas moins bien à ce v6 b6 à
froid face à face à gieten s'est du coup
c'est fait mais si c'est des cons non il
est mal ces mises en arrestation après
mais ça c'est facile c'est facile de
vous prouver que les week-ends ou 3 km
et 2 1 ses meilleures lois de nom ou
bien oui mais pouvant réussir vos
habitants wade 5
il ne réussit lui gratter le plus
apprécié au non non non non c'est du
très haut niveau de beats mary jo c'est
des mecs ont aucune chance en speech est
contraire à 4 se dire oui contre la
crise fonds ils seront démolis en
désaccord c'est encore décalé leur nom
ce train jeu comprenant c'est juste que
c'est un seul il n'y a pas eu de
nouveaux messages j'ai pas beaucoup de
messages dans le chat vous n'êtes pas
active de l'actif
je réfléchissais on est lundi mine de
rien et résonne la tête qui ne bossent
peut-être puisqu'il ya effectivement
après ça m'a l'air de faire du
télétravail sap à l'avant ça ne donne
pas l'impression tout grand chose non
moi moi je fais du travail en ont
confinement
on se concentre pour l'aréna écrit
flottille fait méthode ruiz genre de
méthode au rize 15-12 ces beaux scores
et points 4 nov le marché by trees crise
enfin les blancs ouais faut des cinq
sets b tron vous pouvez faire 46.4
regard quoi l'avant regarde là n'est pas
bien agi contre 1 re des disques et
contre la remise ce qui est après on
regardera l'aréna où tu as ton restera
un peu là dessus je sais pas c'est
parfait m6
il faut à ce schisme hives the damned et
6 milliards cad donc je peux pas été
breaké six fois en fait le fou sur base
des 6 4 je suis même pas elle a fait 4 6
2 7 5
oui j'ai pensé aussi à l'or fin au
cavalier
alors non et j'ai quatre ce serait de la
fed à leucate faute si je venais le voir
c'est pour que vous est il abandonné
dans le new wave ou pas oublier que les
kouriles peut être vénéré sur le juke
ont tendu les civils avait perdu deux
matches ils sont non oui oui un e 4 maps
et line qui est prend 1,5
des quêtes et après un cadre d'un acte
iii intéressant comme des quatre c'est
l'ancien coup là on peut prendre je faut
cette dame gk3 fuite avec la dame ac 3 x
5 et le meilleur coût l'aga d'amendé 4
au 7 mai
mais les légendes le chacha ils disent
qu'ils sont être chaud pour regarder ce
match plutôt que l'aréna pour le moment
qu'un touriste y en a qui veulent faire
la reine un nom viendra de temps en
temps parce que là le match et il ya
déjà 12 à 16
ils vont peut-être pas toute la journée
non je pense pas que ça va mon avis chez
les matches la puce a contenu puis ça
commence à être une question d'ego et
même si c'est sur internet ça devient un
semis amie katia ce que je veux dire
foued ce c'est bizarre ce que font les
blancs quand même comprendre si cet or 8
suivi de fou et 5
ça va poindre elf ça que c'est bien vrai
mouël de 9,3 tu veut bouffer la tortue
est là mais les noirs peuvent pas être
mon bien vous prendrez 3 dans le temps
des trois benoît sont bien et tu bouffes
h deux époux f4 non ouais même fosse 1
le foie schiste il va revenir
oui on s'est vite c'est qu'ils ont de
plus l'assemblage torcéen annonce est
beaucoup plus fort il faut dans ces
cas-là faut essayer de garder a et b1
pour avoir plus de chances de gain par
jeu à 6 un moment bien joie encore mais
bon je peux jouer à 6 et 2 ans et 4 b6
fait mais si ce serait le coup j'aurais
joué les six palettes annonçant ainsi cv
c'est simple c'est d'amener en fait
pourquoi ces coûts est vrai plus en plus
t'as le pion aux questions à ces quatre
la tour 7 ça le truc
d'abord un échec ça marche pas ouais ok
cette dame c'est donc super ces quatre
noms ce que toro 8 cette année à 1,8 md
non mais c'est quand même des artistes
non bâti sont ils sont très faciles mais
[Musique]
c'est quand même un regret qui est plus
qui est plus qu'un seul sur ce site
surtout dommage pour lui un coup de
massue pour lui non pour tout le monde
mais gère aussi pour lui mais je pense
qu'il regrette lui-même de ne plus
pouvoir faire les plus laides
championship et tous afin de pouvoir les
faire il a invité à chaque fois de
refuser les invitations
il a accepté un truc non tour c'est le
966 l'avait acceptée mais on a fini
regard amène hikaru il avait donné une
interview chase 24 et où je pense qu'il
devrait axer sur le v8 6 2 joueurs watch
et saint aulaye dan des quatre noms
gagne c'est très citiez précis pour
inviter des jeunes
une dame qui nous donne moi à 4 à 3 tu
as dit des dames les deux j'avais une
idée à deux dames tremblay de ce simple
même pas il a abandonné mais on sait que
c'est la confiance mais ouais mais
hikaru je crois qu'il a des pardons
chess com ou un truc comme ça et ça
n'empêche pas de a du coup ça c'est les
scandinaves tempo à nom de pouce à trois
reprises dans la 4 e st sous la main
d'un mac app store in a way avec un
tabou la sarre transposant avec 4,5 des
caisses attention ne pas faire fouiller
sa qui s'ignoraient 3,2 kg 4 juste
énorme à l'onf ou c5 c'est pas le coup
le coup c'est fou mais 4000 5ème dépôt a
déjà joué sympa rapide message est
excellent pour les noirs non c'est pas
si simple dames g3 comme ça tant d'âmes
the throne sommes tous pareils du tout
qui je sais que vous savez mais pas tout
le chat noir est exact donc la reina qui
est parti on va m'en va rester un peu là
dessus les mecs sont enfin moi j'ai
envie de
et mathieu je pense aussi profiter un
peu de la news du high level qui et b5 y
aura une rude à 1500 pour ça qu'il est
mieux de cette qualif 4 pour je faisais
4-3 où après l'idée les blanches g4
c'est de jouer avec g4 g5 si je pense tu
contrôles des arrêts clés noires on est
en leur temps à m
qu'ils aient travaillé de simplifier la
donne a empêché ses 5 me à la case aux
trois donc c'est de ne plus attendus ou
ab la paix aurait plutôt mais avait à 5
le feuilleton prise mais cinq obligés à
4 mai sur a3 bien je peux faire à trois
baies 3 depuis ce qui a deux qui avait
foncé 2 du coup il a été quatre donc et
des caprins f1 un mini peu quand même
l'armée qui a été 4 à 2 en premier non
là je fais plus on prend 1,3 à b2 tu
fait tour à 4 la seconde est qu'il prend
des quatre dans l'absolu ce sont sept
branches et vers quel point fort mais
après qu'est bouge le cahier enfermés là
si tu le fais tout de suite le problème
c'est que tu peux jouer qu'avec des fins
qui avait lieu à tu peux peut-être que
faire d'un logement ci peut faire
l'enquêté quatre écuries de f1 qui
émettront gp3 et aya temps qu'on
l'attend quand v3 que j'allais dire
qu'avec les autres aux amphets il faut
contrôler un sinon il ya quelques 300
prend tour à tour prochain à temps on
retourne sur le 4 x 6 l'épaule et noir
gagne et on en salive est gros
aujourd'hui si tu vas ans et 5 14 et roy
dans ses chiens
[Musique]
il a juste pas
la peut-être future a8 direct non non un
athois il sait qu'il prend des 4 c'est
chaud et racaille française c'est quoi
le problème
- ton nom même sèchement la vitesse de
jeu canard ou disent qu'il a mis que
deux minutes pour faire pour faire ça
aux deux des trois feux des trois
cavaliers detroit qui apprend à québec
est en droit d'obtenir sa commande et 2
je préférais le détroit mais après des
trois gagnants
son récit de keke d un tour b 4 c 5
il a raté à l'enquêté un tour des deux
serait de le fou défend b5
mais oui il y ait de nouveau envie ce
qui était pas masqué par marie cavallier
à 4 peut-être à quatre ça semble faire
mal tomber quête encore quelle défense
de l'époque quand même mais pays à
l'autre a raté mais oui l'un atteint un
gain mais du coup le mec se bat
notamment de fin qui a validé cinq pages
2 3 contre une passion c'est encore
gagné de tête
par contre du coup sachant que tu l'a
dominé comme ça tu es mieux autant
maintenant tombé de avait l'air de pas
gagné en poules b 5 dents mais il est
impressionnant et potences et partant
aux défenses qui menace c'est cette
niche ou besa nancroix satire entrer
dans le carré c'est bien de qui tu en
prends ce train là nous abécassis tour à
tour à dubaï elle attend tous rêvent
deux tours h33 bon jeu
un 3 4 3 nuls
quels partis plus ou moins lesnums h 30
annonce je crois au caire les nuages
croix-rouge de 3,5 roi prend à non elle
était nulle au hockey il a juste eu peur
au roi 3 maintenant il va jouer h 4 1
mais son gréement du nom va t'attaquer à
tort sur la 6e et la question c'est ce
que je voulais a pendu ou pas qui joue
le bon allez je comprends pas quand il
fait la pendule sans faire des chèques
je pense que j'appellerais sémalens
défaut de waimes et genre là pour un set
mais tour à st il voit pas trop
l'intérêt que ça les gêne à rouhia soit
enfin de connexion sphérique chose qui
va pas tu veux pas très vite
c'est complètement con ce qu'il fait
ailleurs il a craqué mentalement même il
atténue je crois pas ça va suffire mais
ça c'est les échecs comme partant pour
presque ça fait partie du jeu gym link
n'est pas du différend
clearly le game high est pas content et
il est inouï aux il ya une écriture a
réussi flaguais nagua il a eu à flinguer
le tag contre roeck deux parties avant
music awards
c'est vrai que le ps pour moi ce derby
le schisme et away non c'est bolchévique
stream mais l étude
mais non mais il y avait maté le il y
aurait fait tomber le roi cavaliers
d'options contre roye tour c'était sale
aussi rappelle quand tu à bouffer les
deux pions là qu'il a joué la pendule
things prime moyenne est la dermatite à
c'est pourquoi sa part on insulte et ou
quoi ah [ __ ] j'ai un regard partir en
vacances ensemble ouais je vais je vais
faire un smiley je fais des smileys
vas-y je m'emmêle aussi je m'en bat elle
aussi je fais je suis [ __ ] ma merde ou
erin de l'homme parce que les deux par
le russe donc c'est vrai que ce n'est
pas un instrument russ maynard où il
parle le russe aussi donc si ça commence
à insulter des mères en russe ils
entendent quoi on des bouquins du nord
c'était sympa j'ai beau match c'est
sympa j'espère que demain ça aura encore
lieu c'est bon bah on va on va mettre un
peu et j'ai envie de rester sur notre
chatte domine pour voir si ça continue à
1 3 ghz son calme et ses insultes et des
mers et puis c'est ça c'est trop calme
et quoi bein c'est dommage mathieu on
est là on est là pour ça
cover et nature là ouais c'est la kobama
c'est terrible moi ya pas trop de monde
il faut venir voir les liens il mais qui
met sa photo ses reins ouais c'est
barbarian c'est miley acoyer chaud et
par ses ventes avec les blancs quand tu
gardes voulons la case des cats ont fait
un peu mieux ce que je peux prendre
prendre des saints qui après j'ai la
caisse d'éclater laquelle besson c'est
chacun une partie de ces chocs et b5 et
des quêtes à trois fautes 3 en fait le
fait de parole claude ecken c'est un
avantage oui donc sinon c'est pas si
c'est ça c'est un peu mieux quand il a
il a bien fait pas prendre en descente
du coup après coup
parce que maintenant ils prendraient 2e
pouvoir ouais je m y manquait en 17
c'est pas la fin du monde j'en ai
beaucoup d ouais je suis même pas sortir
son gain dans le cas précis
ok ça c'est un code sur thématique
gratter la barre de fou on n'a pas
choisi la partie la plus funky un rêve
est justement justement cette stratégie
cta est pourquoi les lots sont proches
je me prends un kg de khat peut vraiment
une menace mais on peut parler un
mi-temps pour l'empêcher mais on n'est
pas obligé
tu crois faire food et 2 1 mais kg 4
fautes son petit rock peut-être que tu
peux le faire un nom résultat parce que
tu as tu restes dans l'air non alors est
ce qu'il est vraiment là pourquoi pareil
j'ai dû prendre du cavalière est gagnant
dans son auto a fermé sa tâche 3 du
poète arménien ouais ou pas ou alors tu
rothen à un cavalier se tromper et des
deux auquel ses trois plus tôt pour
donner une case pour le fou a par contre
mirta se dire et je vois un coup mal
être un peu trop lent bah c'est pas
aussi déterminant envie de se passer
autant de temps sur comme ça oui sur la
partie des arceaux c'est la trop grosse
prophylaxie un temps kg 15 pour bouger
ton fou à sagem pavé 4 tu te fixes
le trust et qu' il veut jouer bay 5-1
comment tu n'en peuvent pour ses mines
de zinc que fier je bouffe une fois que
je fais c'est 5
ouais 3,7 pour beat
ouais
du coup c'est pas si bête mais peut-être
que manger deux fois alors je peux aussi
jouer b5 peut-être j'en prends pions
prend qu'elle va lier ces trois thèmes
qui feront b4
qui est tombé 50 et 200 soldats et
également chez rock maintenant non
c'était pas c'est quand même pas si
qu'on retrouve sous deux noms n'ont pas
si idiot juge aurait pas du tout pensé
honnêtement ouais mais il faut qu'il
arrive à préparer les cinq soldats et
huit séjours mal maintenant électorat 7
mais peut-être que tu peux juste le
préparer mais j'ai du mal à voir comment
enfin le prince et que tape avec
jean-pierre trois ponts fermés la
colonne à écouter il s'est royalement
bec à tous
en tout cas c'est un petit avantage
blanc à long terme ça je suis plus sûr
tu sais pas sûr attends je vais
bienvenue à 3 est ce que c'est la
cazotte envie d'aller c'est quoi la
peine raconte moi je mets le lien en
fait dans le chat fou juste rejoindre
c'est gratuit c'est automatique
c'est que c'est quoi c'est pour pouvoir
à rejoindre l'aréna en fait
[Musique]
hiroko quai voilà je pense à l'équilibré
les noms elles ont quand même pas de
faiblesse on prête a pas de plan avec
les north shore a joué 54 ouais il faut
vraiment faire gaffe le ding joueu 5 le
fou de foot et deux hybrides pardon j'ai
magnifique c'est à dire qu'ils ont une
part aux jeunes non ils n'ont pas relevé
mais ces mots comme népoty flag à fond
et des qui se fait flinguer déjà la
dernière fois il avait fait le truc
falala damien l'hébreu m'enfin y'a flag
et flag et celles à limoges
ok même annoncé 5e
ces cinq 5 ans acquise et de calais ces
deux des quatre cinquièmes et à 5 pouces
et 3 tempo plutôt pomone plutôt chiant
et nick et b6 au moins deux ça veut dire
quoi flag et ça veut dire faire tomber
l'adversaire parce qu'en fait sur les
pendules avant il ya longtemps
quant à être pendue mécaniques y avait
un petit drapeau vert y avait quatre non
juste un mois mais vous prenez aussi si
il y à tout prendre il faut prendre les
machines qui essaient de mais du coup la
position aux élections parce qu'il ya un
cube est placée contre un pion à et sur
un peu attendait bien même je suis pas
sûr qu'ils pouvaient le bien le faire
tant qu on est peut-être même pas mieux
je peux c3 et c5 des cats effacé 5 des
cas d'enfants faire gaffe parce que le
fouillis contrôlera 8e mathieu fait pas
peur ces cinq cavaliers où je prends ces
captures à 17 ans prise si je prend 1,5
à des cinq entreprises et sur les 4 à 6
contre lui donc le moins pire set
prenant un smic mais ça veut dire que
les blancs sont bien là ça c'est pas
bête pas le foot il faut contrôler a
évoqué tour b 6 uturbey trois t3
maintenant tour à 3 3 mais tu auras
tombé trois fois à cinq tours un tour à
six tours à 3 3 à 8 c'est ce qu'on gagne
je le mets 3,8 à qui des tourbes est
tombé ce tour à cette foulée 6 ok je
peux peut-être faire période
ainsi non si cela de mieux pour les
blancs n'est pas trop content il a fait
tomber trois fous 5 f4 ne l'a quasiment
bienvenue mais bonne pas si longtemps
ouais ouais partie de bonne qualité
manquent cavaliers 3 fait mal non
tomber cette plongée une tonne seulement
pop trop de dans les tours à huit
multi-menaces rien as dans ton menaçant
jean paul ii ou iii des prix mais je
pensais un truc genre tour à 4 on veut
qu'à briller à trois mais l'avion au
carré lieu trois noms mais une bonne
mode technique ci peut pas tenter un c4
ici qu'elle prend des 5 après prise c4
ces trois sets le faut oui vous voyez
ici ça tue il arrête tout joli partir
mais blanc d'organes humains non mais
bon tu peux encore faire tour c'est
cette fois c'est peut-être fallait je
pense enfin ça paiera mais switcher le
défenseur way to rateront mais oui oui
tu sais tu devais faire sauter parce que
là en fait part des recettes de prendre
non mais juste sacrée poussée après
mauvais trop parce qu'il ya un moment il
peut y avoir tout premier set
exact très très bonne partie des plantes
malades mois dans un aussi au début un
peu oui allez faire roi b6 bien joué 20
techniques jusqu'au bout seulement 5 3
mais si c'est un coup que tu peu près
mauvais parce qu'il n'ya pas tant prend
1,6 autres premier set
au mimos l'ip non non je pense je pense
qu'il a oublié que l'autre peut aller à
dame donc ses shows de nous
non il est trop belle case 1 milles
échangés dame en fait s'échanger leurs
forces les taux calculé ok allez
maintenant il faut concéder sa vallée
devrait pas pousser fcd mais bon il va
il peut se rendre potes je suis pas très
haut
incroyable incroyable mathieu valbuena
ce qu'il a fait une bonne partie à non
aux non il n'a pas le droit on la lui
avait attribuée tous fonction des en
fait tu pousses le puant le plus loin
comme ça t'as jamais besoin d'être un
hacker il reste dans secondes donc bon
il a raison de l'ajout et il a raison
juste avant on a vu pire
on axe cherry love s'est su que j'avais
joué un oui mais j'avais souffert tous
une partie il avait fait suivre là
d'après ayant qu'il a toujours en commun
ce qui l'avait expliqué line est quand
même bien malin bas le problème cette
pulsion de violence est en vie john
callas 4 qui est un bon coup mais il
jack avait lieu qu'à essayer de
s'activer
mais bon normalement tu vas quand même
en ces cinq villes souhaité qu'il manque
de respect un peu de là je baille coûte
je sais pas c'est du trois minutes ça
fait pas d'un second dans ta vie et le
truc c'est que ça marche de temps en
temps ce jour ça le problème quoi y'a
trop de pâtes
salut ma route ux et salua cyber yuki en
trois-huit ya pas le respect vrai faux
pas nous faire une épaule égard je
remets liens du club pour ceux qui
veulent participer les gars du tournage
et moi je ferais g3 pour calmer les
ardeurs bien vrai
la partie course et huit caisses des
zincs il ya aussi b5 fougueux v4 qui
gagne et du matériel ou alors qu'il
forçait qui les prend des deux mais
encore une fois parce qu'on en met deux
séries live qui est très mal
ouais mais moi j'avais été beaucoup
mieux très vite ils m'avaient un hacker
donc un vrai y'a des princes une baie 5
essais si ce qui fait perdre sur la
photo prix de des russes y apprend plus
tard type le fou ou bbc l'option safe
quand tu te prends pas la date un tour
bernama cas tu fous bessin qu'il ne
nomme pas trop dans x 8 mm 1 à 6 c'est
parce qu'il veut faire il veut prendre
méprendre tapantes le cingo key buy va
activer le foie après est-ce qu'on peut
pas tout prendre ici il fait repousser
trois dames des cats
dans l'absolu je conseille de prendre
plutôt du cavalier fonde on a le choix
sa force plus de choses mais
attendez-vous matériellement c'est moins
fou des cats
mais c'est moins clair oui il ya du f406
peut-être non à f4 il fait feu prend pas
je pensais qu'il voulait faire dame des
quatre mois pour jouer la finale mais il
y avait des petites chances de nuls
comme avec les fautes peut en poser la
colonne b mais avec le temps on peut pas
jouer 17 retrouvé 8 watts web de
vautours ou un serpent
mais même ces 6 de ris nina le front des
4 est vraiment fort mahi voler une
qualité
allez me faire lâcher un acquittement
oui issue la hune suis issue c'est un
adversaire plus de l'eau le couteau dont
il sut issou tête g5 g4 ça aiderait ton
four catch pas dans quel miracle je f4
pas idiot d'amd 200 un bon coup mais
avec une tour en l2 c'est un peu est
tombée trois la force active et où la
sagem pas du tout tomber 3 il va jouer
f4 prochain ouais on peut encore avoir
une surprise
bref quatre ans il faut y aller la tête
des tours b1 qui peuvent arriver un jour
aussi plus tard ouais non mais tu le
double de f4 et piotr on est ce que tu
peux prendre de la toro et d'amd 8 c'est
sûr bien sûr j'aimerais au moins tu as
ouvert la diagonale de la dame
il reste trois du béton prises entre pro
f 4 1
c'est sûr d'amd 8 et la fait tourner
vers d'abord même si c'est pas terrible
parce que prêtrise roi guézo il n'y a
pas de match des étoiles de way et tu
veux plus prendre f4 ouais après son
léger c'est peut-être un fou d'être owen
non mais non ils appellent ça tombe bien
c'était faire une idée qui était en
l'air dans l'air il fallait bouffée de
kato s'était rué du coup ce que j'allais
dire pour toi là c'est très bien joué
c'était contre attaquer là bas ça c'est
très bien jouer encore je crois que ça
marche non mariés fadam g5 2007
à mach 6 mais pourquoi pas ça je me
donne sagem pareil tu fais juste puis on
prend et ça me permet d'en couper la
diagonale non mais je tombais double il
tombe elle aurait deux dames servent ces
dames 17 d'abord pourquoi tu joues f6
devant on sait si ce doit régner quel
membre mais monte est d'alger cette
manne on change de défense pourrait
changer
dès lors il est mal l'automne mais c'est
quoi le 14 à 6 5 en sa part trouvé un
ton bien c'est pas mal ça ne donne pas
trop pour est pas de même cette fête est
bien jouer adams et seule fois m6 oui au
bio dans les mines on donne trop fou pas
sûr qu'il le voit est fou c'est 8 tu te
donnes des 5
même si sept ans qui va je d'amd 6 tu
dois pas donner ton point fort réussie
serait bien joué mais ça va arrêter un f
dam des deux fils de prince rama yade
arrive cette année c'est à la donne vous
prendrez 6
il est en train de se compliquer la vie
c'est la fausse bonne idée de 8,2 me 8,2
gagne encore non mesdames 1,8 fois ci ça
reste vrai dire les menaces f1 allait
pas 3,6 à une de 8 et 1 reprend du fouet
c'est pas bête non ferreux f2 et en c3
il avance et les gagnants mais il ya des
choses de ne perd plus de temps et
objectivement c'est ma venue leur rnb
devrait donc encore le faire un
troisième c'est bien oise et ça s'est
mieux passé passe il faut juste
connaître le truc c'est quand le mec te
fais à 6 ha faut pas partir si ça va
encore un bref cette fois encore nul 1-1
à sa perte
c'est le roi 2 et angers 7 absolument
consternants faire face au roi g6
absolument à son rêve 7 nuls ont 17
perdant le g5 du sein donc ça les mecs
faut savoir pour mettre tout le temps
leur 11e 7 et attendre et l'autre il va
essayer de te mettre le pion à 6 et le
roi c63 v6 pour aller en recettes
voilà pourquoi il je t'aurais fuite
avant que je vous annonce terme à la
saga une facile le roi est trop loin et
ça va faire du sénat au pire je suis n
ya pas de mauvais coups droits assure
roi j'ai vu de ces cons alors ça c'est
inutile pour g6 au moins le pion il le
support vraiment à temps il ya un piège
de tours jean royer six taureaux h80
ranger cette annonce ça marche pas
versailles a pas de pattes
bonjour merci non bon c'est sympa comme
partie très franchement sa manière les
noms sont là dessus qu'ils ont fait dans
ma came chargeant food
mais on n'arrive jamais à tomber dessus
ces gens fous pourquoi il s'était plaint
qu'on ne commente pas non mais je sais
par où l'on parle plus alors je rends
fou les mois et coûté pour l'instant sur
le mien s'impose à temps c'est pas le
matériel garde un regard du début
j'avais une scandinaves en plus à une
mévente avec 5,1 à vous est donc là les
gars je vais pas aussi le fouillis sial
fait jambes mais même un coup comme
ainsi ses meilleurs que j'ai tricoté
ouais un peu pataud mais d'ailleurs
c'était à dépasser par nul ce qui est un
peu dommage
la cage des 5 bat renzan dessin qui
centralise la case des 5 pour le
cavalier c'est pas si bête mais tyson
mais bon quel dessein que peut-être
viser c3 ouais c'est ça mais bon dans le
détroit qui s'est trop tour bouge
est-ce que tu as peut-être un peu mieux
mais on s'est passé c'est clair que
c'est dommage de perdre trois coups pour
un quart et quittez pas si mal placé ou
tu aurais pu faire dame des cinq tours
des huit courses et huit par exemple
mais alors tu peux attendre comme je cas
pour maintenant faire ta main heures
plus tard la f4 dans ces cas là si tu
avais été chassés entourent sien j'ai
pas trop compris non plus hein c'est un
peu mou parce que tu veux aurait lui
aussi voulait jouer lyon c'est le point
sexuation son adversaire la jeune
actrice ça ça marche si la dame n'est
pas défendu mais c'est pas le cas ici
ouais la c3 c'est un peu dommage quoi il
fit juste un pion à une qualité 1 se
sont évités et pions et surtout qui fait
jouer le coup claude voulait faire
tester ces trois stabilité de face mais
il aurait joué outil peut pas le louper
ce genre de cesson idem mais en plus ses
chances ont joué la finale retour des 1
c2 ses adieux à voir mathieu s'est pas
encore fait autour des 1 c2 ce soir
qu'il y est mais faut qu'il le fasse
ça marche aussi la marche si ray
c'était même plus méchant c'est surtout
rentes à étourdir je sais pas oui je
sais combien verges en full full wet à
la puissance qu'on a vu on ne peut pas
dire que c'est 2005
ces deux bulles je suis pas tombé têtu
peut filer way tourbe et 8
il va filer tête de mort des cinq
soldats et cinq sur l'hiver a pas mal
non ce même plus fort le seimat
étrangers deux taureaux 2 way you lie en
a plein qui font tout rage de l'échec
mais non autour des jets deux tours
c'est de tuer une pièce à roissy
internet faut éloigner le roi des tours
pour pouvoir faire le bas de l'escalier
c'est ça il ya des matins à la troisième
moins bonne partie des gens fourni
d'élan il est là agritech j'avais bien
ça m'a fait rire le jour j'avais un truc
à la télé il ya un mec qui allie choix
de malte c'est un geste héroïque
non non pas du tout cette moderne de
jeunes ont compris
je croyais cts been des comptes en
hongrie des comptes
c'est un philosophe allemand du drame on
ne sait pas ok boomer et écrivent en
tchat
alors oui leaf bon ça s'écrit est re
intel ich9 en allemand d'ailleurs à côté
om de relire mathématicien mathématicien
m'intéressait ralement du coup mais qui
craquent austro-allemand 20e tchèque cez
1906 1955
ok donc c'est une structure 15 bad
les noirs sont bien ils ont toutes bien
placé ils ont chaude plan fait il peut
le jouer c'est assez bizarre ce qu'ils
peuvent jeux partout là le même jeu à 5
était mieux évidemment pas dit non mais
tu peux aussi s'il attaque allait droit
qui a eu 6 kg 5 h 5 taureaux 8 c'est
plutôt pas mal pour mettre un café y en
a quatre bonjour à la dame celle là on
va réunir 60 a des droits mais cette
question de goût marc m'a pris comme ta
foi trois dames g4 qui a eu 6 kg 5
moi je pense je ferai ça mais j'ai donc
juste un peu formaté que gundam gundam
ace 5 et 6 et c'est la fameuse attaque à
l'ancienne rejoint les trucs genre à sa
poupée 5 à 6 8 6 6 4 à 4
on appelait ça quand j'étais petit
l'attaquent ouvre-boîte c'était un nom
de ton club où c'est un an
c'était mon entraîneur qui m'a dit on
appelle cela t'a couvre bottes tue mes
infos 1h 3 m dames en h1 bien qu'allant
g4 et toute la boîte f5
il peut prendre les 5,6 soit chez s'est
regardés à la fin il reste le phocéen
qui vend des fruits qui va générer
encore la finir mais il est dangereux
wade ouais la finale d'avant c'était nul
sans rajout enfin cette ag beau jeu bon
ça du coup c'est un peu plus tôt un bon
coup parce que j'ai rien il va jouer
tout retour au système mais fin d'un
machin tu vas faire dame ait fait
l'objet de deux cents - le fougueux il
est triste c'est ça ouais c'est ce truc
tu peux monter ton attaque je peux
prendre ton temps dams f1 bien rue
beaucoup de défense alors plutôt de
corrections et les dames 1 voilà mais la
dame en fusion quito ça peut être un bon
défenseur disant ouais après qu'est
français deux dames ces deux se peut
qu'elle prend 2,12 à monsieur de il y
aurait plusieurs mais ça peut être un
truc qui peut désorganiser grave annonc
é si on peut faire pionne franck et des
cinq thématiques on laisse la case c4
mais encore une fois on veut jouer
cavalier kung fu à 44 terrible je pu
faire de monsieur g5 way et philip sion
et c'est un des coups de 9,6 alors
madame f 6 2 me de flou attaque à cinq
et tu vas au dessin c'est peut-être pas
main mais des salaires des coûts qui
peut paraître mal un wiki l'un des
objets sans exception logique quoi je
suis d'accord nous et moi je filerai
quand même les pieds avec des 5 ha ouais
mais je te prendrais frais faut 5 après
j'aurai plus et je jouerai maintenant la
lhdaa ouais mais je veux dire par là que
c'était quand même le mieux
ok il tente quelque chose c'est pas bête
mais ça c'est bien ce que fait moi je
prendrais en passant quand même mais je
vois pas de gains c'est pour l'instant
ce n'est pas bête blessée bien joué les
gars est d'empêcher bien jouer f4 bien
joué
mais le truc c'est que c'était pas d'âme
france 3 c'était d'ailleurs je crois
c'est pour ça que c'est moins fort à
temps mais là il peut pas se faire
enfermer la grosse n'ont-ils adam qui
ressort et si tu fais 5 a priori ça fait
pas enfermer mathieu non pas du tout
non de mais du coup il défend très bien
ainsi ok il va dans la case absent il
m'a passé que c'est pas ça pas grand
chose mais il y tue bonne défense mais
ch3 peut-être en badge à terme je
voudrais arriver à faire un carrière 5 g
4 kg 3 seul quai à angers 2 il est
tellement triste bonjour cédric à 5 kg 2
c'est triste à 500 gliders the end and
maintenant bonne partie encore je vais
fixer doublé sera au tour des cinq tours
à 4 et rentrer petit à petit dans la
collection
je pencherais pas b5 s'offrait une
faiblesse en c6 juste sur l'a8 tomber
cinq noms s'ajoutent sajoo 3 2 et québec
catherine gaigne une qualité annoncée
trop et mal an qui avait 4 m way ou v5
et p4 et b4 attention va peut-être faire
tour à quatre baies 4 pour toi pas qu'il
est à 4 et pour moi qui tourne à katia
b33 donc la bécade gagnants d'un jeu wii
aux chips seront prises en kabylie et de
bouger elle a fini par gagner à l'aide
d'un mois la mise en mine de rien les
échances qu'il a fait les lois étaient
plutôt bon pour lui et changer de case
blanche et bien jouer échanger les dames
mais auparavant
ouais c'est stratégiquement grosse
domination des noirs ça joue pas mal
l'a4 b3 et ketura 3 encore mais tu vas
prendre à 3 prendra 4 enfin prendre
trois peut-être en premier d'ailleurs
et ça va gagner c'est une nouvelle
victoire qui arrive
ouais qu'ils arrêtent qui ça ressemble
plus à une partie de 2002 2003 que 1500
à 1700 ground ouais après un seul petit
truc mathieu que je remarque c'est que
on vous toujours mieux compte des
joueurs plus faible parce qu'il ne
laisse plus de liberté mais barnes en 8c
bien je pense que ce dont tu fait tomber
quatre on a apprend 1,4 y y b 3 c'est
quand même assez précis à mérignies sud
est bon il m'a déjà battu d'ailleurs
donc il joue bien les joueurs c'est plus
facile
ok bien je sais qu'en ce moment je me
régale comme bien peu le candidat il ya
les tournois des nordiques a repris tu
regardes toujours et je regarde il ya
des parties de championnat du monde de
correspondance qui arrivent au fur et à
mesure mais t'es tu dis tout ça j'adore
ta part et j'ai vu la nouveauté de
l'année jouer je pense en correspondance
un truc hallucinant que l'ordi propose
pas direct et ce qui est marrant c'est
que sergi qui rien encore donc ça on a
déjà vu cyril offre on peut peut-être
changer voire à raoued contre zurich un
français un mec qui reliera la chaîne
peut-être même qui a acheté le le dvd de
frappe mais c'est pour le noir n'ont pas
les rondes qui est serré lille qui a
gagné le droit d ordi mais vous êtes
vraiment ou feint déjà hier le moindre
avec qui tout bien tout de suite ça
accusé de triche tout le temps c'est la
partie puisque smcp dessins que ça c'est
une position qui a eu lieu à un autre
candidat que j'ai commenté rich manga
ouai donc là il le plan c qui allie les
deux cahiers 3 wii pour essayer de viser
la case 5 même même d'ailleurs on avait
dit que c'est plus malin de commencer
par ses 3 c'est sûr qu'elle et ses six
ans que joseph k
mais après où en gros il n'a pas pris de
l'adamant ainsi si la production mais ça
change pas fondamentalement le 3 ans fut
g5 c'est pas bête en soi jeune homme
plutôt bien en et non 26 2 au 5 mai à
son ailier cette fois retaper réussi
c'est un moment 6 h histoire des fois on
peut faire une manoeuvre cinq fois je
cale fou j'ai trois pour échanger faute
cases noires pour te retrouver avec un
fou de cases blanches à la fin quand un
cavalier qui aura du mal à défendre des
faiblesses ont ainsi cédé 5
enfin vous baissez la prophylaxie jamais
un fauve et sa exploite un coup aussi
parfois pour essayer pour créer des
ouais on a une sorte de surcharge d'un
procès qui aura prises et gagne aussi
c'est après le tour ça j'aime bien ce
type de prophylaxie wade fourbe et 5
tamana c'était faux price is donc la
fois h4 bien joué et il va faire bouger
3 oui ce sujet 5 après on peut garder
encore un sujet si tu fais rien
peut-être bouger c'est ce qui peut être
sympa j'ai six toros est c'est
maintenant fougeux trois jours après il
faut pas oublier après faujas histoire
celle des coups comme ses 80 ans
on va arriver un jour leblanc pour rire
avec tes deux jours sur les courages way
sur les colonnes qui s'ouvre surtout
qu'avec un fonds après le fond l'uci si
prompt à se faire déloger camurac y
avait des fuites en vous mais cet
ailleurs les blancs va faire cinq heures
il m'a dit sur les partis ce que j'en ai
joué en dans les parties pédagogique en
coquille qui avait lutté une bonne
manoeuvre dans l'absolu pour lyon on
sait 6
[Musique]
comment on joue ici a jugé ce projet six
cavaliers le 5-fu j'ai su ce qui éveille
au sein que ça vous mêmes ce qu'ils
pouvaient jamais prendre ou g6 j'avais
bien parce que sa force et la torah les
recettes et se mettre dans le visage
et il y avait plus de karelia fuite pour
chasser le fou mais c'est sain donc je
fous ils étaient un peu éternel on est
bons fous j'ai trois ans on n'est pas ne
pas mauvais mais peut-être afp menacé en
france 60 m qui a été sept mathieu c'est
mazet qui m'envoie un message lui je lui
dis absolument de regarder une chaîne
youtube il la trouve pas selon lui que
nous la retrouverons 5la ainsi revoir
ses lois comme sean bean games
challenger tournée japan rail est ce que
là ils font chier non mais là c'est une
erreur qui est simple c'est trop tôt
parce que tu obligé de prendre du plomb
tu peux pas prendre la tour il avait pu
me prendre mais qu'a t il y avait le
clonage
mais t'as plein de trucs aussi pas et
chacun qui sont cool sur youtube oui
donc moi je regardais aussi mais on est
censé parler d'échec
non en fait il ya finalement je
conseille vraiment récente est sadler il
y
c'est lui il a accès aux mille parti qui
a eu entre stockfisch et donc du coup
par exemple le h4 cage de maxime
il ya des parties entre les deux
aujourd'hui jusqu'à très long sa soeur
c'est hyper important en fait les genres
et les anglaises il ya plein dans buzz
ah ça c'est dommage qu'il n'ait pas fait
des cats
les noirs commencé presque à être bien
là ils laissent le pur le passé et la
symbiose puis on l'a bien qu'arrivant f4
et non mais juste il ya aussi ce encore
plus fort saganne direct et en fait et
en plus ils s'amusent à faire jouer les
ordis entre eux dans les pollutions clés
de la théorie moderne
du coup si tu aimes les échecs et la
théorie c'est je me régale mais tu mais
il ya beaucoup de vidéos mais en ce
moment ils en font une par jour je crois
qu'ils sont vraiment chier avec le
confinement
ils sont vraiment chez vous et c'est
très suivis comme shell n'ont alors
qu'ils sont vraiment celle là c'est
dommage on juste pour les noirs parce
que tous là toute la chaîne depuis elle
est bloquée sur cale blanc sur cases
noires à ses gains très facile tu fais à
quatre baies 3 tu mets ton foutu aura
maintenant il ya un très très facile sur
4 pour passer le roi c'est pas bête
plutôt bien du coup j'ai raté le tournoi
n'était pas pareil cas car il ya
beaucoup de triche mais c'est parce que
nous vraiment honnêtement on n'envoie
pas quoi qui sait qu'ils arrêtaient
c'est antonymes 49 tacle au papier rohff
6 nuls sans rajout ouais mais tu
alternons ouais on alterne c'est pas de
chance mais 3 + 2 et 5 + 0 en terme de
temps c'est vraiment la même plus de
temps que dans les trois plus de quoi
faut c'est qu'à 3 des 3 x 6 x 6 à 4 et 3
c'est méchant mais je proviens bloquer
le pion donc il n'ya pas de triche
paraît tous les jours on dit qui en a
mais nous vraiment dans toutes les
parties qu'on regarde on n'envoie pas
quoi ça joue assez bien mais ça sert
d'aller à de tricher c'est sûr que ça
sert à rien mais de se prendre la tête
là dessus ça fera pas changer de message
ou bien mais raison garder faveur c'est
pas nouveau grand maître quoi jamais
cette erreur de scories de gaffes
ok ça joue bien ça des bons plans quoi
mais y'a pas triste mais de mauvais
parents m'ont dit pas non plus mais un
peu ok f4 ça se gagne tranquille non il
ya plusieurs façons or moi j'aurais joué
à quatre pour empêcher 3 et 5
là il rentre maintenant on sait le bon
plan mais juste tu commences à te
compliquer la vie alors ça doit encore
gagner sur un champ d'un milliard à
dufour barça c'est un peu con way mais
h5 maintenant un saut à 5 5
nelson guerreiro f4
vous apprends f4 f5 f5 itunes qui
atteint 5
c'est dommage parce que 6 0 après f4 ça
devenait chaud ça devenait très chaud et
maintenant h5n1 il a oublié avec les
noirs et alary contre 1 900 ses shows
s'il serait demi je dirais pas j'aurais
compris que je suis moins fort qu'un
2000 mais je suis meilleur qu'un absents
quand même une absence et son sais pas
trop trop un
ouais bon après peut-être une personne
par exemple dommage qu'il ait pas pris
ff4 ouais mais oui donc du coup les
blancs là j'ai un truc si la personne
revoilà partie fait f4 d'abord on perche
le contre jeu du roi qui montrent un
talent bons plants à trouver le bon plan
mais juge joseph 4 d'abord tu bloques le
roi je coupe le roi et après tu montes
temps ça mange pas de pain blanc mettre
un jour wade 500 m c'est du tu te forces
à calculer un truc on n'a pas du tout
besoin regarde tago mago tago mago mais
qui jouit française et ça va faire une
variante des changes mais bizarre avec
les blancs qui décide de ne pas mettre
le pion en d4 jamais vu ça l'excès c'est
une petrov ouais c'est petra foule et
noir ont finalement attendre plus tard
il a fait foot est roi fou d2 il a rendu
le le très haut noir quoi oui après il y
en a peut-être qui joue sur les comptes
anonymes il en est le moins bon que
leurs vrais loups ça ça peut arriver
ok se précipiter sur le faux aussi c'est
pas m obligé parce qu'il va pas
s'envoler
il est venu et tu peux garder tes en d4
c'est toi il ya la région les gens
payent des deux fous des points qui
pouvaient prétendre un petit avantage
bon après prendre c'est pas mal non plus
qu'elle veille à trois pourrait
peut-être prendre dans la seconde c'est
peut-être si vous l'avez la part des de
f3 pour arrivant des quatre c'était
quand même
logique non ça c'est normal hein ça
sympa mais bon on change une king est
fait
tiens on va voir le leader du tout le
leader l'ex leader du tournoi
il est 3eme maintenant mots griffonnés y
en a vu le jazz mais ils jouent tous les
jours ils jouent bien et aujourd'hui
joris et paquito fimo fait le taff un
avis tout à l'heure elle est bien je
n'insiste futur jeu on préfère
normalement être le fond le 7 pour
éviter exactement ça c'est à dire 1 4
avec des idées de saint caprais mais bon
ici c'est jouable et 9e 5 et du coup ça
fait une estonienne un premier engin qui
joue h3 d'abord pour éviter de se
prendre kg 4 3 les noix parle des fois
juste donné le pion en 3 mai pour ouvrir
mais quasiment jamais réussi à
comprendre si c'était bon mauvais quand
j'aurai la star indienne
il ya les deux il ya les deux écoles oui
oui non parfois c'est bon pas forcément
les meilleurs par là je n'arrivais
jamais à comprendre dans la situation si
c'était bien ou mal l'aipac et enfin
[Musique]
dégager 4 et ça c'est déjà vu tempo
ouais bah ils le préparent un petit peu
réussir il faut dire
le jeu se 3 ok il joue hyper vite siècle
je pense qu'ils jouent trop vite je suis
pas convaincu de ce qu'il est en train
de faire ça il ya maintenant les noms
dès qu'on pense je joue à 5 b 4 le faut
des cas de vol un pion en défense une
dame b 6 à 5 beckham fois ci ce sont des
huit façons d'amener trois oreilles à
l'import du jeu une fois 6 1 mais c'est
bizarre de me laisser fait pas une bonne
partie maugrey bon après ça devrait
suffire
oui objectivement même fou prend b2
préfet pas fou prendre deux îles et pas
moyen non temps des limites
je pense qu'il faut être très froid free
fly et découvre c'est du rhin oui gk
toile ouais mais le mec avec les blancs
jouent pas mal mais réfléchit pas trop
c'est assez étonnant en soit j'aime pas
la première vue t'as pas envie
d'échanger qu'elle n'est pas juste on
prend de 3 thèmes fait genre super mal à
tour en l'air des grandes et 3 gagne une
qualité peut-être deux hommes font pas
de casse pour la dame pour francs il
faut prendre f1 wheel et c'est au fait
plutôt des bons réflexes métro joue trop
vite alors c'est pas prêt il fait ça ces
1600 de réfléchir maintenant il veut
jouer la finale plutôt bien joué le coup
les deux thèmes très moche capital plus
embêté il va tomber rapidement
ouais ouais le tour des cadets allait
bien mais si j'avais pas pensé à ce que
tu as dit mais tomber
tu aurais tu gagnes tu mets ton cul en
1/4 tu vas rentrer tranquillement
il ya aussi tour des huit tours d2 avec
comme y avait des menaces liées au
passage c'est dommage
nicolas de jouer aussi vite quoi ma
série 13 30 minutes et a été mieux y en
a un qui dit le tursan un temps n'est
jamais tombé sur lui c'est le pur hasard
en fait mais en plus je crois que je
t'ai déjà vu ton pseudo je crois qu'on
est tombé un peu c'est une fois sur son
futur je suis sûre est que nous faire
moi je pense qu'on avait déjà vu une
partie pas aujourd'hui où je suis
quasiment sort bon mais il a quand même
réussi à retrouver du jeu avec les
blancs ouais non c'est quelqu'un qui a
une bonne inscriptions pour la taxe mais
qui est je trouve
madame si un homme f4 sa force l'abandon
ça calme
ouais ce sens c'est un bon jour avec une
autre il a le réflexe pour un club tu
peux plus se faire arnaquer avec eux
plus loin cet effort et il arrive au
hockey bien tricks qui protège la tour
garde thomas buffel depuis bruxelles
vers le haut on l'a vu aussi le jo oui
mais thomas thomas pellen nom d'homme
sincère l'ancien frêchiste le tas couvre
bottes en très bonne reprise et noir de
jeu ces cinq allemands après un jour 2 2
une folle tu lui fais pas trop il avait
pris mauvais que l'on prend à vue ouais
en 5 minutes vous n'êtes pas obligé de
prémont mauvais dans la nature même en
trois minutes d'ailleurs dans
l'opération en trois minutes les blancs
se retrouve un peu mieux ce qui est
assez étrange
il était moins bien des cinq noms samir
jouili peut-être viser la case d3 3
autour d un bon achat faut pas chercher
compliqué photo d un c'est un petit plus
sans risque c'est un petit peu mieux
pour les blancs de la casse et cinq aux
cavaliers ah non il est dans le dur à f3
c'est une bonne idée mais juste j'ai
peur d'eux m'a fait bien la case aux
trois genres que 4 et 10 dames v6 déjà
les là je peux encore faire d'un v6 qui
est rare qu'ils apprenaient simplement g
mais je repère un pion de tête manquée
prendre si on prend pour ces huit jeux
permettront à votre père trop en fait un
truc intéressant à être parce que je
pensais y avait le 4 mai à qui le jeune
homme bien ici on doit f3c manque de
c'est un coup logique hein tu veux
chasser le fou mais il vaut mieux faire
un choix parce que tu tafer but hongrois
il aux canons c'est quoi tes ouverture
principal mathieu moi j'en joue beaucoup
à temps fou et sens qu'il faut donner la
balle à calage écrit un livre l'arago
zine j'ai écrit un livre donc il peut
quand même considérer c'était un truc
assez principal chez moi mais quand
j'étais gamin je joue beaucoup d'elle et
qui n'aide pas énormément mais
maintenant je joue un peu le tour tu
fais de la merde en fait quand j'étais
petit maintenant non moins d'un jet de
la mine jojo tout le temps là nous
faisons
tu peux plus tu peux plus te permettre
susu belle à l'équipe carolo se connaît
j'aime bien martine en pro de chelsea
qui serait souvent parler
ouais j'en ai joué mon prochain single
à quelle déception la prochaine c'est
que cette saison quand même un peu ça se
joue à rien on prend des 5 km2 les noirs
maintenant on se rend là pourquoi il
réfléchit calcul mais je vois paraître
sens il va te reprendre et 5 t'abandonne
donc il ya eu peut-être qu'il a cru
qu'il est ancien mais ça ne marche pas
il arrivait à wimille tôt un accord
parce que tu en prends des 5 tours 5
si je perds la dame aurait tué deux fois
dalle 3d blogueurs du coup à donner une
pièce de man next
ouais mais selon ce que j'ai vu il avait
fait défection de réflexes fonds qu'ils
font pour répondre lanine zoo j'adore
j'ai toujours joué à une dot ma vie la
mère lagoon fait j'ai un peu arrêté pour
jeu pour le gain quand j'étais petit
j'ai eu beaucoup de benoni maintenant
joe cole est indienne je venais ckoi
officiellement ton prochain tournoi
prévu top 2 ça peut encore et à lui
manquer top 12 est ce que tu donnes
convient de pourcentage de chances que
ça ait lieu
c'est juin c'est c'est début juin moi je
suis top 5 % max 5
max n'a en fait de bruit c'est qu'en
plus un truc internationales sont
personnes dans une pièce tu sais que
même violeur wimbledon 1 et à lille et
qui se passe à mende jjp reporte pas
c'est juste ma source de revenus
principale dans l'année moi j'ai lu un
truc mathieu j'ai lu un truc ça re ce
que ça vaut mais que les compétitions
sportives internationales ne reprend
reprendre et au mieux au mieux en
septembre
mais après c'est la turballe il faut
voir ce qu'ils vont faire saison blanche
c'est ce qu'ils vont faire juste décalé
ça je ne sais pas
maison blanche n'importe où les
provinces et ses katas mais en fait je
sais pas si les gens se rend compte que
c'est que c'était le joueur d'échecs
professionnelle mais la première
division française
c'est juste assauts de re numéro un
parce que c'est la seule qui fixe est ce
que tu peux nous donner des chiffres
c'est trop indiscrets honnêtement je ne
sais pas mais gère les meilleurs
français jean maxime je ne sais pas
combien il a mais c'est énorme ce qu'il
a joué une dernière avec nous avec
asnières un grand maître qui touche
c'est pas entre 200 et 1000 la partie
entre 200 euros et demi et moi je
pensais plus entre 3 3 402% les services
en clair il ya dix partis et entre trois
et cinq mille euros suivant suivant le
maître et j'imagine que des bacs au des
frais signer ça gagne même plus mais je
sais même pas combien il met donc c'est
quand même énorme pas ces normes
c'est quand même pas mal du tout qui dit
il n'y a pas que notre ligue a aussi la
ligue allemande qui niveau de tous les
meilleurs français jouent à viernheim
mamas et lydie abergel en grand maître à
baden tabac cros riffs mon maxime
d'avinel gozzo de werder il ya aux mains
fraisse major lazer c'est marrant c'est
qu'ils jouent au stade de bram de foot
le werder de brême il ya une photo de me
coûte le français qui a été hyper fort
qui vit à bordeaux dès fois je le croise
dans la rue le monde qui jou rs cannes
s'achève avec tous les meilleurs de
bordeaux je sais moi les blancs sont
bien maintenant il faut des coups des
quatre grands un rottweiler de marche
marche ou pas cavaler prendre un pont
d'or prend des huit tours d un gagnant
si tu fais m6 histoire 17 c'est pas si
clair mais là je fais tourner un on a
été obligé de jouer à ça mais donc
prendre à 7 et poussé in the bold
mais si tu fais qu'aller 17 y avait des
m18 nat
le fan mate mais c'est plus beau ouais
donc c'est le blog marc qui se passe
bien
déjà hier il en a gagné beaucoup un gris
de quelques blackmar et samir au pain
nous avait dit qu'il était spécialiste
du black marais que et qu'avec ça
m'était les points blackmar après ça
fait pas mal protection mais on
progresse pas vous même
c'est le genre de verture typique c'est
pas bête pour gagner des parties mais
est ce que c'est ce que je conseillerai
en fait je sais pas c'est pas si clair
moi quand j'étais petit je joue beaucoup
et je conseille à mes élèves ainsi qu'à
ses trois points 5 sur 6 yens j'ai gagné
beaucoup plus facile mais à vous demande
rien de jeu des grandes lignes le bec
marcelo gambeat c'est en fait c'est le
nom d'un joueur allemand c'est sa dîme
heures black mardi mais ces deux
personnes manière des forts ouais ouais
une histoire personnelle un peu spéciale
pour le moins qu'on puisse dire
on peut aller voir la meilleure personne
il ya mieux mais bon c'est un beau jour
de tacles on peut aller se voir venise
mais tu nages m c'est quelqu'un qui a
étudié tu as fait une vidéo non ce n est
que du nord et non je n'ai jamais fait
encore frais qu'en face c'est un je
t'aime bien entendu parler pourtant
j'avais déjà parlé mais je n'ai jamais
fait de vidéo sur monsieur moi je
connaissais pas je suis tombé sur un
article de lui dans sur lui dans
l'europe et tchèques ya vingt ans même
plus mais c'est un gros joueur a
aujourd'hui atteint que je crois que
c'est un des seuls mecs qui avaient un
score positif un score possible contre
table me michel henry j'étais tombé
dessus parce que c'était un très fort
joueur qui qui dit dans une interview
considéré que c'était un des plus grands
son côté
c'est quelqu'un qui avait beaucoup
d'enfants ne sont jamais celle qui
s'était foulé si ce nom il faut
développer le pion death d'abord des six
dessins kefu descendre ou des cinq
d'abord mais comme souvent si vous
développez pas le pion des le problème
c'est votre pouce et 8 k way ou alors
des fois ça marche avec un b 6 foot 7
foot est interdite car apple a déjà joué
publicis dans cette position de précise
et là je croirais mathieu c'est pour
finale tant le 10 ou le pin à tort ne
peut pas être remis en cause de mathieu
une attend 1 quand même c'est donc il a
jamais geoff molson est vérifiée copine
à tort il a peut-être vu un string il a
peut-être vu un truc on ne sait pas non
mais en fait dans l'absolu il a
peut-être joué cette idée j'arrive tout
des trois clefs blanc existe avec l'idée
de jouer ici et déjà c'est pas quelqu'un
sait si ce processus est celle du couac
et me lancer ses trois associés 2 puis
les katas meute dams est en faillite
doit être fatigué je donne des tapes
gratuitement et c'est peut-être pour ça
en fait que les gens te bat antonymes ce
qui est à faire un peu de tricher car il
arrive qu'elle prend des cas tu gagnes
un pion dans lequel 2005 avec même fou
et 55 ouais non ce jeu moi j'ai moi une
cure mais je préfère caïds et kate
winslet faux seins que je menace notre
jeu masqué pensait d'eux dans le train
fou seront rois d intérieur mat hockey
bien jouer mathieu gymnase des 5
à caraquet jouer contre eux des 200
alors fêter 1200 c'est fatigant tu finis
par le nominer venir je pense que ouais
mais bon c'est pour progresser il faut
faire ça c'est bien
vous prendrez cinq honda me prends ça un
petit poussin d'un point échec faut des
trois et on a gagné tous les fous
prends-tu temps des petits pièges que je
veux défendre cinq ans mais il a fait
comprendre bien jouer pour confronter à
quoi doit être le seul coup logique dé
5,1 2,3 et on a juste gagné un pion il
s'agit juste heureux maintenant ils
amèneront un temps est-ce qu'il ya pas
f5 dames 3 4 et 5
ça marche c'est joli mais par contre
quel procès de fous ces trois marchés ya
wade un dés la tourache en défense oui
mais bon peut-être autre chose nommée f5
est vraiment bon poésie ouais alors
attends je veux faire un petit point sur
le classement je regarde devant côté
mercure l'arsenic est allé voir les
premières places oui barbarian et on les
a vus tous les premières nous avisent
avait bien joué des bétons faut il n'y a
pas d'algues vertes aussi qui peut
remonter d'ailleurs si on n'a pas vu way
qui démarre une partie banane verte
ah ouais parce qu'il a un regard et la
30 points mais il a le strict dont il
peut il peut y aller il ya une banane
verte ans dans le pseudo ils jouent
contre la furia chaude 1900 avec la
bande xtream donc une française
brillante classiques n'ont pas ya
plusieurs plans prenant à 6 les cinq
fawcett petit rock dans le beh si c'est
l'ancienne ligne mikec aussi j'ai jamais
compris pourquoi j'étais si à la mode
points non j'ai toujours pensé que
c'était un peu mieux pour les blancs et
un bernard serin des gens ne connaissent
alors là les gens connaissent bien parmi
toi même c'est celle qu'elle prend des
quêtes mais bon maintenant l'ancien il
ya une super partie devant une forêt
stromae indique qu'à la d2 il ya deux
ans
donc top-12 on n'était pas en avait on
avait un peu que le sujet tout tout seul
mais a donc si ça joue pas par équipe et
qu'il n'ya pas les os les olympiades ont
été reportés d'ailleurs je crois
belle année d'après mais du coup ils ont
pas dit en fait ils ont enfin dix ans
savent rien mais ce qu'ils ont ce qu'on
sait c'est qu'il y aura pas de donostia
et ils ont dit que l'on aperçoit 2021
hockey plutôt été 2021 aia mais est ce
que ça veut dire qu'ils décollent tout
donné c'est à dire que le championnat
d'europe 2020 en lune de miel en 2022 et
ainsi de suite ou une année à deux
témoins deux bretons n'ont en moi qui
suis entraîneur de l'équipe française là
encore ce fait c'est à dire que l'année
prochaine et aura peut-être des gros
revenus entre guillemets ouais mais ou
pas le temps de tout faire
là c'est comme je sais pas si tu as vu
il y en a plein de trucs
ils disent on fera t-on phrase tu étais
mais prince et que si tout le monde mais
cet été au bouscat maintenant pas tout
faire c'est un peu ce qui se passe avec
roland garros là je crois que ça a été
re des places et ouais il avait fait un
mois deux ans ou le mets en force
et ouais alors c'est pas du tout passé
mais je veux dire par là que tu vas
avoir beaucoup de beaucoup de choses en
calendrier qui peuvent se chevauchent et
on en discute avec libye par rapport aux
candidats c'est qu'on révise ainsi il se
passe quoi si tu m'as tu lis candidats
aux dates de la singer par exemple ils
sont censés faire une bonne intelligence
mais à un moment donné tu vas forcément
de chevaucher avec quelque chose si tout
si tout est déplacé mathieu c'est que je
te montre une jolie vas-y g6 food et cat
way fait un coup d'attendre jean assice
on s'en fout on prend et cette robe à
franges et 6,20 me prends pour f1 - g7
je vais faire fois m6
il faut aussi tout reprendre mais
manquait juste courage et 7-6 6-3 achète
les gens disent ça peut marcher les fous
pas tout le temps mais ok je lis will a
fait 6 ou des cas très rock
là j'ai envie de te dire il furia bonne
chance non normal on là tu vas te faire
mater quand même mais froid h est ok
maintenant un iphone 5 la fois f5 gagne
la dame concert de lilly rush et c'était
sûr qu'il allait le voir alain mathieu
donc il va remonter puisque il va se
retrouver ailleurs maugrée fola et pas
qui tu m'attaques sophie mots ça peut
être très très chaud pour lui on l'avait
votée au début j'avais bien joué
ouais mais d'arriver à en gagner encore
paquito fimo j'ai l'impression qu'il a
les bons appariement aussi puisqu'il a
rejoint 13 cents et on va voir contre
qui tombe parce que s'ils continuent à
gagner ça risque de trier tout c'est dur
de le rattraper jubile ouais après faut
qu'ils gagnent au canadien joue aussi
1300 maintenant web alan verte bananes
vertes qui sont bien pacs de films en
compte qu il est à parier pour moi je
vois pas parié alors il doit y avoir un
souci attend va essayer de le chercher
pakito fimo qui joua tu vois le truc qui
s'épanouit à il sait pas il s'est pas
relancé dans une partie en fait
qu'est-ce qui se passe
pourquoi est ce qu'on ne réussit pas
l'avoir paquito film ok on l'a
maintenant ils jouent contre 1,12 cent
elle tombe bien tu vois mes mots greffe
au lay qui l'a rattrapé
s'il a un strike sur un mois ils sont
tous là ils sont tous sens trahi en
strict mais mais du coup
[Musique]
le seul qu'on a pas vu c'est très cher
docteur tôt ce mois mais il est loin des
rings et remontera pas mathieu et
remontera pas parce que la facture alors
combien de points la victoire en france
2 ça vaut 4 mai trichet n'ont pas facile
et il est septième et il a plus de
strict dont il peut pas remonter mots
griffonnés par contre s'ils gagnent vite
mais je pense que ça va être intéressant
il reste encore du temps il reste du
temps il reste du temps il reste seize
minutes ainsi paquito il mais il met 2 3
points à mon avis il va au bout en haut
là c'est quoi ça une écossaise cécile
ouais ouais bon pas la meilleure
ouverture du match homérique les noirs
moment est ce que c'est possible surtout
chasse comme de regarder une partie en
direct d'un pote
ah bah oui suivante son pseudo tu
rajoutes en ami et puis tu tues le club
serbe reste tout à fait possible
bah c'est ce qu'on est en train de faire
on réalise vite et d'ailleurs ouais
c'est ce qu'ont fait 30 québec est il
veut faire d'un cran ouais c'est logique
c'est bizarre alors je sais plus si je
vous contre contre une main bitstream
les mêmes vitrines sont très dangereuses
qui a vu le droit voire monter
aujourd'hui basque français 3 des 6 1 il
arrivait à s'en sortir correctement et
n'a donc pas convaincu par dominique six
mais surtout qu'adam g 5 c'est space
mountain développe totem après il veut
gagner la finale tranquille ce qu'on
triche attentes hamas parole qui nous
disent son pseudo j'avais 8 sur 8 mais
j'ai complètement déjoué après il était
bien et puis là il a lâché
comment on fait pour voir la fameuse
zone biskri
faut payer c'est cher attends je peux
leur trouver un lien je peux vous
trouverez un lien si vous voulez j'ai vu
qu'il ya deux différences nationales à
paris on à paris un package de marque y
en a plein tu les fais pas celle ins
elles sont gratuites en téléchargement
c'est beau
qu'est ce que le marché a beaucoup de
gens qui les a réussi pour sa petite
finale il s'est affaibli donc il est
évidemment mais revenons à la tête
ouais c'est pas non plus la fin du monde
des six fois aux six car j'ai mis la
main besoin d'un peu de classe sur votre
profil chess comme télécharger les
avatars personnalisés pitch trim
à quand le pilote chez les ch espié
faucon de chasse pied pour les pieds f 5
5/10 ans non qu'ils jugent de fou 17
il va faire un temps g8 qui va pas se
laisser prendre le 4 juin
ce qui fait une bonne partie la main
vitrine verte là c'est un pays que
j'aime ton je dois tout
non mais là j'ai quatre îles et il va
faire ses cinq c4
c'est ça la typo mes frères si c'est pas
encore à 6 après talent font enfin
quoique faut prendre si c'est à dire
j'existe à du jeu encore ton recettes
indien attaque la tour de 8 et 6 ans du
coup ça va ça va passer sas à tanger
nord il a trouvé aussi 6 tous et si ça
fait mal
ça fait très jeune homme études veut un
4 4 c'est quatre fois à 2.4 et tu as
encore de l'actif mais bon là on sait
faire tourner est ce qu'on pressentait
f5
j'essaie de faire marcher le 5 mai 5 c 4
f 6 truites des tum en guinée tu manques
dit des tas même roi dès 8 heures ce que
tour d'élite ça donne pas mal ça faut 8
qui revient m'améliorer un x 4 b
s'affairaient cat way le tueur turquie
en a fait demi sur 12 pour le moment
est-ce qu'on devrait t il appelle
beaucoup de strict donc du coup il a
pâli beaucoup de points et paquito fimo
qui a 48
il joue entre qui maintenant mais le
tête il est déjà au dessus en fait de
quito film
oui mais en fait j'ai en fait moi j'ai
la caméra qui est ta caméra qui au
dessus il joue contre eux qui jouent
contre eux vivent 72 caisse qui gagne
salle à mon avis le tour ne répond pour
lui parce que les autres minières
il est peut-être moins un but clair il
est dynamique comme cause où il manque
un faux de cases blanches et
participèrent importante pour lui 1 h 4
fois je crois peut être une idée à ce
type de position pour jouer contre la
faiblesse insiste c'est genre de truc un
peu invisible des fois on n'y pense pas
de faire un sketch rejoint très typique
dans ses structures françaises de
mathieu c'est un supporter de jeu qu'on
ne devait plus petit et le dip ou le pin
a tant aimé que c'est aussi
insupportable pour les grouillots quand
tu joues contre toi quoi c'est la même
chose à l'envers est assez mûr dans les
noirs ils vont essayer de jeu pour eux
cinq bien je fous des 6 c avec toutes
les pièces noires sont placés pour jouer
simple donc cela va peut-être aller
ça l'homme marchait tactiquement ça il
faut prendre si on prend kg 4 c'est pas
possible ça a l'air d'être un bon goût
et pascal carrier limites ou pas même ff
x h3 et ça tu feras 3 donc la jouer un
coup et il faut h3b 5 je te fais à 3 et
après 4 et tutus triple quoi en force 1
mais non mais tu me l'as aussi le
couperet insisté francs des saints ah
oui quand tu fais fois je crois tu
pourras prendrait six prendre des 5 et
jouer le clou à gré donc fois je crois
direct bonjour bientôt en voir
ouais tu arrives par exemple tard il
reste 10 minutes de fausses trop bien
joué là il est un peu dans le dur
qu'est ce qu'ils peuvent faire dams et
7,1 ça s'apprend menace c'est vrai il
peut me faire comprendre à saint cloud
prend 7 3 qui a eu quatre donc là les
blancs doivent réfléchir c'est un moment
important
pas facile avec les blancs paquito
fillon qui joue bien là même peut-être
qu'il fait les jeux à 3
c'est du coup ici leur idée va être de
mettre un truc dans le iv à un moment où
celle-ci se débarrasser du tricot f6
ouais mais tu apprends en coupe pourquoi
je serai moins bien du coup à se dire ce
f4 des quêtes un peu fun 9,3 pas bête
c'est le fameux wem et non prendre part
au sein s'est fait quoi non non ne
feront pas cette fois tu prends et je
prends à l'écouté 6 ouais ouais c'est
chiant donc je pensais que tu prenais du
pion je voulais faire cavaler h5 à la
faute et c'est chiant mais fou des six
qui allait prendre des cinq faut prendre
un bon mais je vais faire peut-être tout
reprend du coup mais non mais je suis en
fait si l'âge et f4 et que j'ai le temps
de revenir aux trois têtes ça va encore
mais l'appareil ou non mais les noirs on
gagne pakito attend food aussi ce que je
tourne j'ai cinq ainsi manqué de gaz
moi je remercie la laisser cette tour
est ce que tu menaces de la primaire 4
ok tu vas voir prendre 30 ça ça que
c'est si grave à yaya touré froid c'est
complètement l'union ouais mais bon il a
fait ça avec tours g5 la page rouach est
on road maps est qu'ils évaluent à cinq
feux qui à chaque je peux prendre des
cinq ans et la partie c'est parti non
ici sauf près d'annot 2e pour menacer le
6 mai et pranger trois prises six prises
dès cette horde à main ans écologie a je
crois que ça j'attends je pas faire f 4
non mesdames en inde allemand aurelius
protège tout prix g3 je prenne du
prendrait west ham heures tu logique il
a fait à me2 mesdames eux deux qui est
étranger 3 n'était pas sur le site web
on achète il faut prendre dès cet échec
est tout reprend ouais mais je rioja des
600 prises à la fin
tu prends courage c'est rang prise échec
prend si tu prends g6 francs 8
ok mais elles n'ont à son mieux c'est le
matériel égal dans le sac
au caire il faut prendre si si la fée
prises six prises aux prises aussi
précisé il prend du coup les blancs sont
mûrs ans on gagne en on l'envoya des
seins qui tombent
il a joué trop vite avec sunrise à 2
minutes encore ça peut se jouer chaud
chaud avec elle les ein hod des blancs
dans une position de l'union la tête tu
commences paroisse g2 non ok car il ya 5
moi je fais qu'il prend des saintes
pascal tous les invités chez ouais non
tu prends tu prends évidemment mais là
je fais car à ie7 et accueille cette
3ème set qu'elle tout cas mal tu as le
mot grémeaux griffo leïla qui a pris le
lead mais ramène à un cavalier donc il
est pas mort mais par contre cavaillon
eux je crois que c'était la fausse bonne
idée
un chien un chat un cas les affaires va
faire tour 4 kg 3 restants lui toujours
lyon ouais non il va ya
et l'autre qui semé mal autant la 40
secondes et je pense pas qu'ils au pied
favoris au nom de la partie à la clé
tu connais mieux sous main - je sais pas
il faut dire d'un particulier affaire
qui prend des quatre le tas 40 secondes
en dieu qui du quai cet échec mais bon
tu obliges 3 et 6 kg si royal 7 pendant
non mais ils sont avec arrive de tomber
sur la pendule ils sont pas assez forts
mathieu car ils n'arrivent pas à jouer
il prend 20 secondes sur un coup
du coup ça fait pleurer la petite ouais
la kf3 accueille aussi s'il vient tout
défendre par f5 n'y a plus assez de
temps pour g6
ah non pourquoi qe3 mais y'avait
fouleront tour sinon ah oui j'avais le
bac est un an quelque 400 g 7 3 808
juste à l'étranger c'est ouais mais
quand bien même tu a pas grand-chose qui
tu attends t'es peut-être pour g5 pour
zahia castro ouais mais pour essayer de
faire maths ce que tu as plus de tant de
façons
voilà c'est fini par trois il va même
perdre sur l'échiquier
bon après c'est à quitte ou qui habitent
ce qui est de tout impôt après c'est pas
encore fait parce que 24 minutes que il
reste 4 minutes et maugrée du coup ça va
jouer sur un mot grec qui va essayer de
gagner mais juin mines sont ouais bah
justement si la gagne il va il va
reprendre le litre mais bon il faut qu'
il a plus trop de temps ouais mais yom
nuit je te donne comme un oui mais il va
falloir qu'ils la gagnent en faisant
tempo tempo thème pourquoi et un an plus
tôt ou alors pas qu'ils n'en est pas
quitte aux trois minutes il peut plus
gagner c'est fini
l'ex jury là il a pris sa partie peut ne
pourra pas gagner en 3 minutes
normalement
yann ogla la victoire de maugréer sais
quel point c'est le cas - nous qui
serait ex-aequo les deux on va aller je
crois qu'il a un meilleur des partages
maugrée bien meilleur pourcentage de
victoires mot grec qui rentre dans la
finale c'est couillu quand même moi je
vais plutôt fait qu'il prend des six ans
j'aurais joué milieu de jeu
mais bon il doit se dire j'ai change
tout et je gagne ma charge utile à une
minute pour gagner en fait sa loi la
france dans ses buts un bon tels que le
web mais faut voir c'est pas tout à fait
pareil parce que le petit décalage le
0,1 de l'ags le temps que ça arrive là
tu leur en torrents des six skins
qu'ainsi qui aurait la skin si on il a
fait mal mon gré qui a craqué elle c'est
fatigant à mathieu ouais mais il peut
quand même gagner mais juste là il vient
de perdre un temps fou à cerner à jouer
à ces jeux sur skins y est ce que c'est
il ya combien de points ou pauvres à ce
qu'il ya deux points pour le moment il a
gagné une seule partie ce qui suit dans
le tournoi il est en train de faire a
gagné le tournoi un mec c'est vous qui a
eu 2 quel point ces trois temps le 3
bientôt 8
je tenterai tombé 5 peut-être genre le
cavaly pas mal fait qu'ils avaient lieu
deux tours h5 le beau jeu que deux tours
8e en 8 c'est non à kiev cette foutue 5
kg six tours à chamakh oui oui je sais
c'est justice il appelle au nom au nom
pgci s'agit comme aromate à aiguines la
pièce comme il avait la gagne du tournoi
là je pense qu'il devrait y arriver non
au niveau du temps c'est à dire qu'il a
role is d'un 20 secondes 25 secondes
après le truc c'est que t'as pas la
compense la petite qu'on pense du lag ou
quoi donc c'est plus difficile que si tu
as quelque chose avec 10 20 secondes
sachant qu'il ya trop de cet impôt est
dur à dire je pense que qu'initie un
faux pas
il abandonne pour le temps qu'elle fin
du suspens
une mini twilight a raison il ya moins y
perd du temps c'est horrible avec le
petit lac c'est horrible à villa il joue
pas tout tout tout tout tempo là en fait
j'ai joué supremo ville le fait pas à
hilla il a perdu la connexion non non si
mon autre côté ils méritent pas de le
gagner ce tour à mathieu parce qu'ils
avaient le match en deux tout à l'heure
j'attendais il a raté le match en deux
il a raté le match en 2 allez va pousser
géant
non ça va pas suffire il avait il avait
la victoire entre les sous les doigts
j'ai quatre ans donc j'étais dans la
tour ce qui s'y cache jaune qui donne et
balades vertes qui prend la deuxième
place qui a enchaîné les nuls ou les
victoires et paquito qui paquito qui
passe c'était chaud à excellent la coi
quand tu vas voir qu'il a raté ma tombe
de numen dégoûté ouais on veut leur
montrer s'est joué là dessus en finale
après il a donné une tour en ans qui est
également le domaine justice échec si on
prend tous rachats mat
dommage dommage ça a été un beau finish
elle encore dit pakito premier banane
verte deuxième maugrée troisième relish
sûr qu'on ait vu au début tu ont acquis
joué par al troisième gâte rien nancy
d'orbea n'insistez pas mal mmo visscher
002 qui avait cette partie sympa aussi
au début tu turque et la 10e tard hall
qui a craqué julien qui a fait 10
ennemis sur onze qu'il peut pas un seul
tour en entier je crois qu'ils mangent
pas ce qu'il fait à poutine à tort 8 sur
étienne pinatar nationale il est là quoi
syrie vers les 9 12 ans durent germain à
dent dure aussi funky flex est vrai tout
ça c'est dans le dur c'est donc du
risque il ya des petits lots qu'ils ont
fait après tu peux pas savoir contre qui
ils ont joué une grille dès que tu vois
il avait fait il avait fini tête top top
5 avant hier et aujourd'hui il est dans
les choux un seigneur ce tournoi c'est
d'être un dur c'est ton allure frères
des gens qui ont joué deux rondes
derrière oui non ça c'est normal j'ai dû
arrêter joué 25 minutes 10 séries la
vraie mais venté dans le dur quand même
peu importe peu importe pour moi
j'espère que vous avez qui fait on se
retrouve à toi duo avec mathieu on se
retrouve quand on se retrouve on a eu
jeudi
mouais
ce que tu m'as dit à l'armée j'ai pas
vérifié normalement way juste de le voir
un truc mais pour lectoure et sinon de
demain ce sera avec sami robin est
normalement jeudi avec matthew shipp
non mais je suis en train de voir
aujourd'hui se vérifie le calendrier est
ce que j'avais un court mais mon cours
il est à 16 heures donc ça va donc c'est
passé 13 heures c'est un trésor ouais on
peut pas changer les horaires baie james
et 13h 15h c'est pas mal quoi ta le truc
c'est que tu me dises et tu mange le
midi et 14 heures je sais pas 14h05 sa
coupe vraiment toute la journée pour
tout le monde trésors encore les gens
qui sont en pause qui peut faire plein
prier moi il y en a comme celle de 13 à
14 dans leur pause déjeuner ouais voix
ou qu'ils peuvent regarder ou et du coup
tu changes décadence et ça c'est du
fairway fait 3 + 2 et 5 + 0
parce qu'ils sont quand même les deux
cas dans ce principal j'ai l'impression
et mercredi ce sera fac du coup
patrick sait rien des parties
pédagogique avec des invités comme on
avait fait à l'époque
ouais ouais ouais bah ce soir
normalement avec fable mais si tu es
chaud pour en faire cette semaine ou la
semaine prochaine avec prochaine tu le
tiens con way écoute
non bien sûr bien sûr on va faire ça
alors avec le confinement je sais plus à
calais à quelle heure il est moindre et
en plus c'est une changement d'heure du
coup ça vraiment tout décalé cabaye dit
ma mère veut pas que je joue entre 12h
et 14h
mais pourquoi d'ailleurs je sais s'il
sert à ça est bizarre est ce qu'on peut
faire du pu l'être diront flex va le
truc c'est que ça exclut quand même tous
les gens qui jouent pas en bullet quoi
donc c'est un peu après il y en a un qui
joue au calme en bullet avec cette
occasion se blesser à un peu comme le
seuil de réfléchir je trouve que c'est
les deux les deux meilleurs qu'à lens
mon seul regret une partie j'ai perdu 15
secondes et j'avais plus assez de temps
pour le faire tomber autant que j'ai
fait nul et ça va péter ma série a mais
c'est la vallée ont rejoint la date un
peu de matériel me taper temps le matin
ça arrive souvent ça ça arrive souvent à
mathieu du coup on se laisse moi je
ferai donc du coup le direct avec fans
ans et 20h30 métal sera en avant je suis
pas sûr a pas changé d'avoir mais de
toute façon vous suivez les chaînes
chaise comme l'expriment vous avez dire
en dessous et
[Musique]